[Muisic]
theresident: Hey YouTube.
Every year in Davos Switzerland the worlds
top thinkers and leaders gether together for
the World Economic forum.
Tlg847: They discuss issues like global poverty,
climate change
>> Energy
Khayav: The HIV AIDS crisis
Communitychannel: Information technology
anonygirl1: Disaster relief
Gingeronymous: Corporate citizenship
geriatric1927: Economic development
>> Education
Gingeronymous: and global governments.
theresident: On the whole these leaders are
asking themselves how to make the world a
better place.
Tlg847: This year, you get to join them.
Khayav: You can make your voice heard in Davos
by uploading a video right here on YouTube.
Communitychannel: With your answer to
>> The Davos question
anonygirl1: What one thing do you think countries,
companies or individuals should do to make
the world a better place
geriatric1927: in 2008?
Gingeronymous: Upload your ideas on video
and submit them right here on YouTube.
Tlg847: Starting January first, you'll be
able to vote for the videos that you like
best.
Communitychannel: Some of the highest ranted
clips will play at Davos in late January in
a special screening for all those in attendance.
Theresident: And all the great leaders and
thinkers in Davos, they'll upload responses
to your ideas.
Khayav: So tell everyone how you think we
should make the world a better place in 2008.
Anonygirl: You never know, your idea could
be the start of something big.
[Music]